so this is element number 35 it's
bromine it's really quite fantastic as
you can see it's a liquid but it's a
really really volatile liquid as I hold
the tube more of the bromine is
evaporating and going into the vapor
phase you know bromine in the UK is
extracted from seawater just off the
coast of Wales just off the coast of
Anglesey
because there's a highest bromide
concentration on the western seaboard
it's really quite fantastic element very
aggressive they're very very reactive
and that's why it's stored in this glass
ampule bromine is a red liquid
the name Brahmas comes from the Greek
word meaning the stench horrible smell
it's quite easy to make you take a
solution of bromide salts you can find
it from the sea used to be take the sea
from Anglesey but it's even better from
the Dead Sea you bubble through chlorine
the chlorine displaces the bromine from
the salts and the bromine comes out of
the water after when you do reactions
with bromine you have to be very very
careful because it forms a very very
aggressive vapor because it's such a
volatile element it's one of only a few
liquid elements it is used in a variety
of compounds particularly those that
stop things catching fire so called
flame retardants but if you have a
plastic case on your television or your
computer monitor it's almost certainly
contains bromine fire retardants
Tennille it's now scouring the glass to
make it brittle so it'll open very
easily and now we will pour the bromine
into the the bottle so you can see the
liquid bromine at the bottom and then as
the bromine starts to warm up it'll mix
with the air so chemically it is not
it's chemistry is not as important as
some of the other elements that one
should never say that because it is a
key component again in the catalytic
process for making
plastic water bottles I think that's
been a good demonstration of it there
isn't it
you can see the crunch of graduation
yeah